- I mean, it's okay
to change their mind
because it's a novel virus
and you learn new things.
What was outrageous
about it was to treat
the scientific inquiry
as this monolithic thing
that's written in stone.
And so if you go, if
you run afoul of it,
then your voice needs to be
censored because, frankly,
you're not following
the science,
Dave, that's the attitude.
And also the fact that
questions that were
ultimately philosophical
questions or policy questions.
Okay, we have this virus,
what degree of restrictions
is appropriate?
Are there other goods
besides just preserving life
against the novel coronavirus
that we should preserve?
Those aren't
scientific questions,
and yet I find extra class
by trying to shoehorn
it all into...
They basically tried to push
their policy preferences
and their philosophical
assumptions as
scientific claims,
which of course they're not.
You know, a statesman
or a stateswoman dealing
with something like the virus
has to weigh various things,
not just one virus,
but also other sources
of threat to human life,
like loneliness and
depression and joblessness.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is the op-ed
editor of the New York
Post and the author
of "The Unbroken Thread:
Discovering the Wisdom of
Tradition in an Age of Chaos."
Sohrab Ahmari, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you, Dave,
thanks for having me.
- I am really glad to have you,
and I read the book this
weekend and I really thought
it was fascinating because
in many ways we come sort
of from different worlds,
sort of from a different
school of thought,
but I think that the
conclusions that you came
to in this book are very
similar to the conclusions
that I came to in my book,
that I think Ben Shapiro
has come around to,
you actually referenced
him at the top of the book,
that Jordan Peterson
has come to,
and I'm looking forward
to chatting with you,
but before we do anything,
I know you wanted
to address the room
that you're in right now.
You're not being held
hostage, are you?
- Yes.
Not being held hostage,
not being interrogated by some
Eastern European police state.
It's just that my own
apartment is filled
with rambunctious kids.
So therefore a
neighbor of mine is,
who doesn't live in his
own apartment, really,
so it's a kind of
dilapidated place,
is kind enough to
let me use his place,
hence the weird
wire on the back.
It's the best we can do
under COVID circumstances.
So bear with me.
- That is the story and
you're sticking to it,
and you are doing this
from New York City.
So you're in crazy New
York, I'm in crazy LA,
how's life in New
York right now?
- I think it's getting
a little bit livelier.
The mask insanity is,
you could see people not
wearing masks outside any more,
which is a relief, but,
you know, as you know,
in terms of crime and
disorder, it's just growing.
- Yeah.
So before we get into the
specifics of the book,
I'm curious, what really
made you write the book
and really focus on
these 12 questions
that, we're gonna go through
each one and discuss each one,
but what really brought
you to this conclusion
that this book had
to be written now?
I mentioned to you,
right before we started,
that the subtitle, "in an
Age of Chaos," that was
about to be in the
subtitle of my next book.
And then your book literally
came across my desk
and we changed it all together.
But we are in a time of chaos.
- Yeah.
So in my case, it's a
book I wrote for my son,
Max, he's now four years old.
When I started
writing it he was two.
And I'm really worried
about the kind of man
that our contemporary
cultural-political arrangements
will chisel out of him.
He's named after a great
Catholic Saint, who is
St. Maximilian Kolbe,
who was canonized and
is famous for having,
chosen to die in place of
someone else at Auschwitz.
And to me that, Kolbe's
sacrifice exemplified
an account of freedom,
is really an older
account of freedom,
which defines freedom as being
willing to limit yourself,
even unto death, that
accepting limits,
accepting sacrifice,
accepting duty.
And my fear is that
my Max, if just left
to our own culture,
will inherit a very
different account of freedom.
One that defines being free
is just kind of keeping
your options open and
getting ahead in life
in very materialistic terms.
And so the book is my attempt
to tether my son, and,
hopefully, maybe the
reader to that older,
for lack of a better word,
traditional account of freedom,
and the best way I can do that,
I'm not a philosopher
or a theologian,
I'm a journalist
and a storyteller,
is to try to poke holes in some
of our contemporary certainties.
And so I do that by posing
12 questions that are
either unasked or that our age
assumes have been supplanted
or made unnecessary,
science has basically pushed
them aside or what have you,
when in fact they're still
pertinent to what it means
to be fully free, fully human.
And then I explore each
of them through the life
of one great thinker.
Some of them kind of
predictable, maybe C. S. Lewis,
St. Augustine, but others
will surprise readers
because they're not figures
you typically associate
with the term tradition.
And it's a kind of an, you know,
it's a genre that I
invented in the sense
that I pose these questions
and then I explore
each through the narrative and
the drama of one life story.
So the reader, when he or
she reads it, will just,
will not be hit thick
with philosophy.
You're drawn into a story
and that's what
propels each chapter.
- Yeah.
And you ended really on a
nice note with a very short
note to your son and you
hope the book has done.
So let let's talk about those
12 questions and you lay
the book out in two parts.
So part one which is
the first six questions
is the things of God.
Part two is the
things of humankind.
So the first question is how
do you justify your life?
And it does seem
to me right now,
there is a huge amount of
people, especially young people,
that can't justify their lives,
so they're acting out in
all sorts of crazy ways.
- Right, at their most
extreme they say that
life is not worth passing
on in one way or another.
AOC said something
like that with respect
to climate change, you know,
why would you bring
child into the world?
And that question really
is a critique of scientism,
not of science, which is
a perfectly noble endeavor
that's unlocked lots of
useful things and helped
unlock the mysteries of,
really, the cosmos and nature,
but the attitude that
would apply the scientific
outlook or the scientific
way of looking at the world
to the whole of life.
And so the reason I
start with that question
is because I think a
lot of young people,
especially like you said,
think that because we know
a lot about the Big Bang
or cosmology, philosophy
and religion have been
made superfluous, you don't
need metaphysics any more,
because, you know,
we have the big bang
or we have evolutionary theory.
And what I argue in
that chapter is based
on the life of C. S. Lewis
who was a great critic
of scientism in
the 20th century,
is that there are certain
questions about, you know,
what's beauty or
what is beautiful,
why is something beautiful,
why something ugly,
what it means to be fully human,
what it means to fall in
love and so on and so forth,
which don't have...
They have right
or wrong answers,
but those right or wrong
answers can't be formulated
using facts, which is the
product of scientific inquiry.
And so, yeah, I mean, I have
to get rid of scientism first
if I'm writing this
book for my son,
because he he'll be
bombarded with the idea
that Neil deGrasse Tyson
has made Aristotle unnecessary.
- Yeah.
So, of course, you were
writing this during at least
a portion of the lockdown
and COVID and everything
else that's going on.
And one of the things
that we've seen, I think,
for the last year is just
the absolute destruction
of the elite class when
it comes to science,
that people no longer
trust the experts
because the experts
basically change their mind
every week for the
last year and a half.
And that that's
really no way to live.
- I mean, it's okay
to change their mind,
because it's a novel virus
and you learn new things.
What was outrageous
about it was to treat
the scientific inquiry
as this monolithic thing
that's written in stone.
And so if you run afoul of it,
then your voice
needs to be censored,
because frankly you don't,
you're not following
the science,
Dave, that's the attitude.
And then also the fact
that questions that were
ultimately philosophical
questions or policy questions.
Okay, we have this virus,
what degree of restrictions
is appropriate?
Are there other goods
besides just preserving life
against the novel coronavirus
that we should preserve?
Those aren't scientific
questions and yet
kind of expert class by trying
to shoe horn it all into,
they basically tried to push
their policy preferences
and their philosophical
assumptions as
scientific claims,
which of course, they're not.
You know, a statesman
or a stateswoman dealing
with something like the virus
has to weigh various things,
not just one virus,
but also other sources
of threat to human life,
like loneliness and
depression and joblessness.
- Do you think we needed-
- Sorry, yeah.
- Yeah.
Do you think we needed
sort of a philosopher class
that could have been
working alongside
the scientific class
to deal with this?
So we have a political class
that works alongside of them,
but that we really needed
somebody else to discuss
those issues, alongside...
- I wouldn't put academic...
I majored in philosophy
and I obviously,
I'm a kind of amateur
lover of philosophy,
so as the book, but I wouldn't
put philosophers in charge.
I think ultimately it
has to be statesmen
and stateswomen and, you know,
elected bodies, which is,
that's how our government works,
but it would have been
nice to have had not
just Dr. Fauci, but
ethicists and bioethicists
and other people who
would, and frankly,
pastors and religious figures,
because that's an important
dimension of human life.
If they were all informed
and then a statesman
chooses from among them,
rather than elevating
one form of knowing,
one form of knowledge,
which is perfectly
legitimate in its own realm,
and making it into the
sort of idle, where,
and if you cross it,
then you're against science.
- So, that's actually
the perfect segue then
for the second question,
which is, is God reasonable?
And as you may know,
I made a pro-God
argument in my last book
as I was defending liberalism.
And what I found was this
is where a lot of liberals
sort of get disjointed.
The Bill Maher
liberals, let's say,
sort of get completely
out of whack when you say
anything about belief.
So I'll let you answer
your own question there.
- Well, lots of religious
people also get out of whack
in response to that,
which is that the liberals
will say that religion
is only a matter of
feelings and therefore
it's sort of irrational.
And some religious people
go along with that.
And they will say, yes,
my faith is just purely
based on revelation,
and it'll be unreasonable,
and it makes me do
unreasonable things.
At its most extreme
you have radical Islam
of that kind of view,
that says, well,
God tells me to kill the
infidel and there's no
arguing with that.
And so the chapter is an
argument for, you know,
basically the classical
proofs for God and for the,
specifically the
medieval mode of reason,
which I argue was a more
capacious and generous
account of reason, that
said that not only can
you reason about, you know,
what you could see through
demonstrative knowledge,
I see certain changes in
of seasons or I observe
regular movements of the
heavenly bodies and that tells
me something about them,
but also I can then
reason further beyond
that and not relying
on revelation at all,
or the Bible or what have you,
just using my natural reason,
I would have to find
some way to explain
why all this change happens,
so what is the ultimate
cause behind all of these?
And that, as St. Thomas
famously concludes each
of his five proofs
for the existence
of God, that's what
people call God.
- Right.
- So it's a case, really,
for what's called
natural theology.
You know, what you can
learn about God not using
the Bible, but just
using your human reason,
and the fact that this God
would allow you to know him
by your reason suggests that
he's also a reasonable God.
So a God who doesn't call
you to kill the infidels.
- What do you think about
the sort of micro versus
macro argument when it comes
to this, that, you know,
I know plenty of
non-believers and atheists
that are perfectly
moral people and decent
upstanding citizens,
but at a macro level,
at a societal level, it
just simply cannot work.
You actually get into this a
little bit later in the book,
so we'll get there
too, but that, it just,
it doesn't scale, basically.
- Yeah.
I mean first of all,
there's an argument from
just looking at history
that some of the worst
regimes in the human history
have been the atheistic ones,
because if you remove
some higher authority
that checks human
power and say, well,
man can do anything he wants,
that's an invitation to
Stalinism, that's an invitation,
that has been an
invitation to the horrors
of North Korea and the
Chinese Communist Party
or what have you,
but more fundamentally,
I mean, look,
the people who are making
claims about what's good
or what's moral, in a way,
in St. Thomas's terms,
they're already arguing
for God, because
if there's something
that's good then there must
be something that
is the most good.
And is something, that
thing that you most imagine
is the most good is, you know,
what is what people call God,
because there are these
degrees of perfection.
So I think that when
people say that,
in a way it's an
invitation to God
rather than a refutation.
- Did you happen to see
the clip that went viral
a couple of weeks ago of
Jordan Peterson talking
about God and belief
with Tucker Carlson?
Did you see that by any chance?
- It was probably on that show,
that "Tucker Carlson Tonight."
I love it, but I haven't
seen that episode, no.
- There's a really
extraordinary clip,
I'll gladly send it
to you where Jordan's
basically talking about
belief in God, and he said
that when he was about 25 he
decided to tell the truth,
meaning for the truth's sake,
that no matter what the
outcome of saying the truth
not that everything
will be good,
but it will be the
best possible outcome
because you're putting order
into the world as opposed
to putting lies out there.
And he said that was the
ultimate expression of faith,
believing in truth just
for the purpose of truth.
And I thought that
was as well explained
as I had heard, basically.
- I agree. I agree.
And order is the first
law of the cosmos,
and my own, look,
I was an atheist.
I decided I was an atheist
when I was 13 years old.
And the way that I made
my own way to believe in,
first of all, a God,
and then ultimately,
a personal God, was because
of the conscience, right?
Like I had this voice inside
me that directs me to try
to do good and avoid evil.
And it seemed to
hint that there was
an objective moral order.
And I sensed when I was at odds
with that objective moral order.
And then I had to ask
what is the source
of that moral order?
And ultimately became the,
there's a God who is
the Lord of that order.
Now, scientists might say,
well, that's, you know,
the voice of thousands
of years of evolutionary,
kind of, ingrained behavior.
Sure, as a how answer or
an answer to a how question
or it's your synapses
firing in your brain.
Sure.
That's, again, an answer
to a how question,
but it doesn't answer those
why questions which find
those sort of richest,
fullest answer in God.
- That basically that thing
that sits behind us all
the time that sort of
is your moral compass,
that kind of led you there.
So that gets us actually to
question three quite nicely,
why would God want
you to take a day off?
You mean we're allowed
to take days off still?
- I don't think many of us are,
and I live as harried
a life as anyone
where I'm constantly, you know,
right now I have my phone
on airplane mode and it's
keeps making me twitch. (laughs)
It's always happening.
But the chapter is really
a case for the Sabbath.
And it's told through
the point of view in life
of Rabbi Abraham Joshua
Heschel who was a great
Hasidism figure in
the mid century.
And he had, obviously,
he'd escaped Nazi Germany,
much of his family had
perished in the
Holocaust, and he comes
to the United States
and he sees some
of the same restlessness
that had disturbed him
about Europe in the first half
of the 20th century, where,
as he saw it,
much of life was devoted
to making conquest
in what he called
the realm of space.
And the realm of
space is the realm
of geopolitical conquest.
It's the realm of
economic competition.
It's the realm of doing
better than your neighbor.
And, you know, some
of that is legitimate.
Those are important goods
that you should try to secure,
but he argued that you
also need to give some due,
some time for the realm of,
well, the realm of time,
which was the realm
of the Sabbath.
It's the realm of the
eternal where you actually
declare peace on your
neighbor for a day.
You'd declare peace in
the economic competition.
And in doing that you
find an inner liberty
because you're setting
aside all these kinds
of material attachments that
define the rest of your life.
And, you know, I
argue in the chapter
that there's also kind of,
setting aside all the
religious dimensions,
there is a kind of
temporal secular benefit
that in the sense
that, our lives,
we were told, getting rid
of the Sabbath would be
a source of liberation.
And in practice what it's
meant, it is liberation,
it's liberation for the market,
it's liberation for
the corporation,
it's not necessarily
liberation for the family,
it's not liberation
for the worker.
And I should mention, this is
a theme throughout the book,
that's something that tradition
proposes and looks like
a restriction on our freedom.
And you're like, oh,
I don't want this.
In fact, once you lose it,
you realize that restriction
was a source of freedom,
and paradoxically, the loss
of the restriction makes
us less free.
You're more harried, you're
at the mercy of your boss.
- Well, as you may know,
I try not to tweet
on the weekends.
And I usually tweet
a goodbye on Fridays.
I'll be back on Monday.
And Ben Shapiro made the point,
you'd know that Jews
have basically been
doing this for a
couple thousand years?
- Yes. 3,500 years. (laughs)
- It's been around for
a while this relaxation.
Do you find that, especially
now, because of social media,
that this is of particular
importance to take
the Sabbath, whether depending
whether you're Jewish or
Christian or whatever,
whether it's Saturday or
Sunday or a whole weekend,
do you think that the social
media component has really
made this more complex?
- Well, I mean, I absolutely
think, I mean, I see, again,
I see it in my own life.
I try to take
the Sabbath, for Christians,
the Sunday Sabbath, I try
to take it seriously, but
there is that twitching,
like I said.
And so there has to be,
you have to impose
discipline on your own life.
I mean, I favor certain
restrictions like limiting the,
as Senator Hawley has
proposed, limiting the infinite
scroll or what have you, but
at the end of the day, look,
you know, you've gotta
take ownership of this.
And there's so much to
be gained from turning
everything off and not being
a slave to that ghostly
blue glow, you know, 24/7.
- You're gonna join
me for my August off
the grid this year?
What do you think?
- Is that your? Okay.
I do it for lent, but...
- I do it for all of August.
- August, the end
of my book tour
for this book, as, you
know, it's a grueling...
So that might be just the right
time. I'll think about it.
- I may have to
officially challenge you.
Question four, I think this
was particularly poignant
for my liberal friends
who are still struggling
with sort of shifting
or seeing what I think
a new conservatism is.
Can you be spiritual
without being religious?
Because a lot of liberals
say they're spiritual,
but they're afraid of saying
that they're religious.
- And that's about 20%
of Americans now identify
as spiritual but not religious.
And what I argue in the
chapter is that the problem
with that isn't the religiosity,
it's the spirituality,
that a lot of these
Americans do all sorts
of religious things.
They do hot yoga,
They drink only,
I don't know, whatever,
hot peppers and juice on
Fridays and what have you,
those that have aspects
of liturgical kind
of asceticism and
self-discipline in the body,
but they don't have the shared,
kind of public account
of ultimate meaning
that religion brings together.
Religion is a
combination of those
kind of ritualistic actions
with some ultimate account
of ultimate meaning.
And when you have just
the ritualistic aspects,
you're doing it just for
yourself and there's a kind
of, it's private.
And there are all sorts
of things that happen
in traditional societies
that take religious
ritual seriously that you
don't access from that.
So I tell the chapter
through the life
of Victor and Edith
Turner, a pair
of British anthropologists,
completely atheistic
communist party members.
They go to Africa as
anthropologists to study
tribal ritual, and they noticed
that these tribal rituals,
as silly as they may have
seen to other anthropologists,
actually have this important
function in society,
they help resolve what
would have otherwise
been intractable conflicts.
They remind the powerful
that they're ultimately
powerful only to
serve the lower.
And generally, they kind
of provide for a kind
of humane society as a whole.
That's what ritual did.
And they, ultimately,
when they came back
to Britain, their
assignments were done,
they became Catholic themselves
because of what they
had seen, but, you know,
what they would have looked,
if they had seen our
version of ritual,
they would've noticed
it had ritual,
but it's a very kind
of merciless ritual.
So, for example, we have a kind
of penitential rite, right?
If you say something
inappropriate
on Twitter, that's considered
offensive and it runs
afoul against PC rules,
you kind of do a kind of,
what looks like a confession,
I confess to my friends
that I have greatly wronged,
through my fault,
through my most egregious
(laughs) this as well.
So we have that,
but it doesn't have the
other aspects that makes
a penitential rite like that
humane and full of mercy
and full of forgiveness,
it only has the rite
and it's kind of brutal.
- How damaging do you think
it was that in the last
year and a half,
that people were locked
out of going to church
and to temple?
I mean, the fact that
they could do some
of the stuff
privately, obviously,
but could not have that
public portion of this?
- I mean, I tried it,
I personally tried
going to internet mass
and it just isn't the same.
I mean, the mass,
especially as a kind
of embodied element
as Catholics believes
that the Lord makes
himself literally present in
the form of bread and wine,
virtually it doesn't
quite work the same.
And, no, I mean,
I think it was a great
failure on the part
of religious leaders across
denominations and faiths,
to be honest, but they
so readily acquiesced
to these restrictions,
and kept at it long
after it became clear
that there are other
risks to be worried about,
such as people falling
away from faith.
- Yeah.
Although, interestingly, I
think that I'm sensing more
and more people are
coming back to faith now,
partly because of all of this,
the endless chaos of
all of this, bless you.
The endless chaos of
all of this, I think,
has actually led
people back in a way.
I don't know that it will
be exactly in the way
that you would want it to be
or that I would want it to be,
but I do sense some sort of
spiritual awakening right now.
- Is that true? I mean, I
haven't seen the numbers.
I mean...
- I don't know the numbers.
Well, if you look
at the numbers,
they'll always tell you that
there's more atheists now
than ever before, and organized
religion is on the downfall,
but I do sense something else,
because the secular world
went so out of control.
- Well, there's nothing like
mortality to remind people
of the last things.
And so, I hope so, yeah, sure.
- Question five,
does God respect you?
- I think this will,
this is a question where any
number of people will object,
if they think that, look,
my human dignity is just
founded in my being human,
my being, my rights.
But I argue in the chapter
that if you don't think
that the human being
has some special origin
and some special destiny,
then why wouldn't you
acquiesce to all sorts
of political horrors
that, for example,
disfigured the 20th century,
because human beings
are just the product
of evolutionary development
and no different
from other animals, so why
not have mass atrocities
and so forth.
So I argue that a lot of
people today who clamor
for social justice
reject religion out of hand
because they think it's
just a source of oppression.
But I argue that
the biblical faith,
because of the emphasis
on the human person
as uniquely dignified
as made in the image
of God as Genesis tells us,
it's a bulwark against all
sorts of political injustices.
And that, I mean,
yeah, I mean, that's,
it seems an obvious point
to me but I know lots
of people disagree.
- What about how religious,
or I guess cult-like would
be the better explanation,
the social justice
warriors have become?
Do you disconnect that
from God or you think
these things are
all tied together?
- Well, it just tells me
that if you don't have,
and this goes in, maybe,
into the sixth question,
but if you don't have
God in the public square,
the true God, let's say,
then you'll have other gods.
So that one way or another
our society will enshrine
some orthodoxy, some
God, some authority.
And the only question is
whether it's a merciful
and loving God or a furious one
like the God of Abraham can be.
- Right.
So that is really question six,
which is does God need politics?
You could have also said,
does politics need God, right?
- Yeah.
I mean, God doesn't need
anything that theologians
would tell us in their right,
because he's a supreme being,
but I argue that the God
of the Bible, in entering
human history wants
to transfigure not
just our private lives,
but also our public lives.
So our cities also want to,
he wants to transfigure them.
And historically, societies
have always had, as I said,
some altar in the public square,
and so the only
question is which one?
And this is my kind of most
controversial argument,
it's what makes me
get called a theocrat
in the New York Times, (laughs)
but it just seems obvious
to me that, especially in
the past two years or so
when it's become so
clear that the loss
of the a Judeo-Christian
orthodoxy,
whatever you wanna call it,
hasn't resulted in a
neutral public square.
It's just empowered kind
of crazy orthodoxies
that demand that
you bow before them.
- Right.
Well, that's why I
thought this chapter was
so interesting
because I came at all
of this from a different
political perspective than you,
and yet I've come to
the same conclusion,
which is that without God
or some organizing factor,
and we can whittle
that down how we may,
this is what you get,
the thing that we have right now
where we're debating
biological differences
between men and women
as if they don't exist.
That's what you get at the end.
- Right. Right.
And so, I just think
there's no situation
in which you can say, well,
I believe that there are
two sexes, a man and woman,
as genetics and
Genesis tells us,
and someone else thinks
that are 135 genders.
One of those will prevail.
And so I think that a lot
of conservative people
on my side of the
divide, really,
but also some
liberals too, in fact,
a lot of liberals relinquish
their responsibility to say,
no, no there is truth,
about certain things we can
be absolutely certain about.
And your interior misperception
doesn't amount to truth.
- Why do you think so many
people folded when it comes
to issues like this?
Just folded so
quickly, let's say?
- Yeah, I mean, I think
there is a kind of nominalism
built into our philosophy.
Nominalism is this idea
that, it's very old,
it's it comes to us from
the medieval age, basically,
that certain
theologians said, look,
the world what we see is just,
the things in it are too
different to allow any kind
of essential classification.
And none of them would have
gotten to gender ideology,
I mean, it would have
been bonkers to them,
but you take that idea far
enough and you're like, well,
what does it really
mean to be a man?
And what does it really
mean to be a woman?
I know what I am,
but I can't generalize
about that to everyone else.
So that that's the kind of
philosophical root of it.
And then I think there's
a more basic level.
Americans just wanna be nice.
And so if someone cries
out and says, well,
I'm conflicted about who I am,
I might be something
other than what nature
or my body tells me.
You wanna respect that,
you kind of wanna,
you wanna embrace them.
But sometimes that yearning
to embrace and be nice
can actually be really
deadly and harmful.
- Part two.
- Yeah.
I mean, I don't know what
you think the origins are
but that's what I see
of the two, a kind
of philosophical
nominalism combined
with America's therapeutic
culture, like, oh,
but that person is hurting
I wanna acknowledge-
- Yeah, I mean, I
fully, especially the
latter part of that,
I fully get that, you know,
that's where the liberal
side of me, I want people,
if someone feels that they
are born in the wrong body,
that doesn't change
the biology to me,
but I want to have a
society that's as tolerant
and equal for someone
like that as possible,
which I think in essence
is the same thing
that you're arguing for here.
- I mean, you want them to
be treated with dignity,
but what I've found
is that the demand
for that recognition
doesn't stop at-
- You're right, it doesn't
stop, that's the problem.
- They'll say, well,
but then you have to acknowledge
that I've always been
Caitlyn Jenner, right?
And you're like,
well, no. (laughs)
- I was once-
- It leads to
totalitarian places
but out of basically
good intentions.
- I was once arguing
with a friend,
although I'm not sure he
called me a friend any more,
I would call him a
friend, about this.
And he was sort of big
on the left side of this.
And all I kept saying was, I
want these people, of course,
trans people need to be treated
with dignity and respect
and I have sympathy for,
the whole thing.
I said, all that I'm
saying is that can
we just acknowledge that
there are biological
differences between
males and females?
And he said, this is
exactly what he said,
and this is where I knew
the conversation was gonna
have to end pretty quickly.
He goes, "Dave, you're not
thinking about quantum physics."
And I said, you're right,
but neither are you.
Like, to me that was, like,
the perfect example
of nobody knows
what they're talking about.
Okay, quantum physics
clearly was the answer.
But speaking of quantum physics,
part two is the
things of humankind.
Question seven is how must
you serve your parents?
- I mean, easy enough.
I had to include that
in a book written
for my son, (laughs) but...
- This is the chapter you
want to stick, obviously.
- Again, to go back
to the book's themes
is that those restrictions
that tradition imposes
that look like impediments
to freedom actually are
a source of freedom.
Filiality norms,
which, obviously I use
Confucius because he's the
ultimate thinker on filiality,
but you can also go to
the Bible, the commandment
to honor your mother and
father, are actually, again,
another source of humaneness,
and what looks like, well,
why I do I have to kind
of obey my parents,
Confucius always
suggested that you,
especially in your most
period in your life,
your first three years,
you were unconditionally
loved by your parents.
And that unconditional
love taught you a kind
of moral imagination, which
you can then say, okay,
why would anyone love
anyone unconditionally?
I can begin to love
other people beyond
my own immediate kin.
So by honoring your mother
and father you begin
to build these circles
of filiality, where
it ripples out into a wider
community and you build
a humane society.
That was the basis of
Confucian filiality norms,
that they care for you.
And it, the difficult part
of it is that it's
non-negotiable, so
both the Mosaic law
on filiality, but also the
Confucian version of it.
They don't say, well,
I have to honor my
mother and father
if they met my
expectations as a child,
it's kind of absolute.
But I argue that if
you make a condition
on whether or not you
felt sufficiently loved
or loved the right way,
then the whole thing
collapses, but-
- How do you account
for just people that are
terrible parents or a
drug addicted mother
or an abusive father
or some of that stuff?
Like, how do you honor that
properly and make sense
of the world?
- Certainly,
Confucius didn't say
that you shouldn't
correct an errant parent.
So you should try to correct
an errant parent, and anyone,
if anyone is listening to
this and you haven't, like,
literally abusive
parent, you know,
you'll have to stay
with them, you know,
call the police, whatever.
But there should be
some element of love,
even in those situations,
an element of this,
that there is this mystery
that I, Dave Rubin,
literally the shape of my face,
the shape of my nose, I got
that from these two people,
there's no other, and
I wouldn't have gotten
it but for these two people,
and that imposes some
obligation on us.
And luckily, most people
aren't in situations like that,
most people don't have
to deal with bad parents,
but the chapter will
probably be painful to people
who have had legitimately
abusive parents.
But I argue that the
traditional norms should be
upheld even as you make
exceptions for individual cases,
because there's so much
value in a community
in which people kind of honor
the hierarchy of genealogy,
the hierarchy of who
brought you into the world.
I mean, literally, you
wouldn't be here if it weren't
for this union of
these two people.
So they, you have some-
- There's something
there, one way or another.
- There's some mystery
that is very difficult
to just cast aside and
shouldn't be cast aside.
- So chapter eight, I felt
this was very important for me.
Should you think for yourself?
Now I have to do some
shameless self-promotion here,
the subtitle, "Thinking for
Yourself in an Age of Unreason."
How did I do? Should
you think for yourself?
- That book...
So I argue, you should
think for yourself
in important moral questions,
but then in doing so you
shouldn't see authority as an,
true authorities, as an enemy
of yourself that thinks.
A certain kind of
liberal ideology,
I focus on the 19th century
as its origin, always pits
conscience and authority
against each other.
So I have my conscience and
for me to fully exercise
my conscience means I
shouldn't have to listen
to various authorities.
I mean, the paradigmatic one
would be the papacy, right?
In the 19th century
there was this question
because the Pope had been
declared to be infallible,
and a lot of liberal reaction
in 19th century was, well,
this means that the
individual conscience
is at the mercy of this
external authority in Rome.
But the question, I mean,
that's a kind of
Catholic question,
but it extends out to other
realms of life as well,
and other groups,
and John Henry Newman, who
is the sort of protagonist
of that chapter, argued that
the idea of the conscience
as this sacred inviolable
thing only works
and only has power if you
think of the conscience
as the voice of that
objective moral law,
that all peoples recognize,
whether or not their...
Evangelize, they're not even,
there's this kind of
idea of natural law
that is sprinkled across,
whether it's Confucian
Chinese civilization
or Muslim civilization or
Judeo-Christian civilization.
So there's this idea
of natural law that,
and you have this interior voice
reflecting it and guiding you
to bring your life into
coherence with this law.
If you think of a conscience
as a purely private thing,
well, one person thinks
it's okay to abort a baby
at six months pregnancy,
and another person thinks
it's not okay to do that,
and no one can be sure
which of the two consciences
is in the right,
you've really undermined
the idea of conscience,
because then it has no, rests
on no objective supports.
And in that frame,
authority is really not the
enemy of the conscience,
it's its friend, the
true authorities,
the Bible, the
Papacy, old proverbs,
the classical
Greco-Roman tradition,
all of these are
authoritative supports
for your conscience, not your
enemies of your conscience.
So if you constantly set them
up at odds with each other,
you're gonna get rid
of all the authorities
that protected your conscience
and then your conscience
is gonna be at the mercy of
corporations, advertisers,
political demagogues
and so forth.
But as you think of your
conscience as this special
thing that needs authoritative
supports and you ring
it with those authoritative
supports, then you don't,
you know, the next populist
demagogue or, you know,
fake news meme or whatever
it is that you encounter,
it doesn't sway you
this way and that.
This is a different
way of seeing
about conscience and authority.
- Yeah.
Do you think our founders
really got it right
when they set up our
founding documents?
Because it seems like they're
respecting both of these,
this sort of empirical,
these are God-given rights,
and also we want you to live
freely and live in a way
that makes sense to you.
- So this is a
complicated question.
I'm more sympathetic to some
of the founders than others.
You would probably guess this,
but I'm a big fan of Adams,
who said that, you know,
our constitution is made for
a moral and religious good.
I think you would agree with
this given where you're...
I haven't read your new book,
but given what
you've said about it,
that the rights that
we cherish need to have
a moral substrate.
And if you chip away at
that moral substrate,
I worry that you just
have kind of an insane
rights culture and that's
kind of what we have.
- Yeah. That's sort
of where we're at.
Don't worry, the
book's not out yet,
but I'm gonna send it to you.
Chapter nine or question nine,
sorry, what is freedom for?
- So all the classical
traditions define freedom...
Both, again,
the Greco-Roman and the
Judeo-Christian tradition,
define freedom as doing
what you ought to do.
Doing, fulfilling your duty,
becoming who you are
as a human being,
as a rational animal,
a political animal,
and not merely just having
choice to maximal autonomy
and maximal choice.
The chapters focus
on Alexander Solzhenitsin
who famously disappointed
a lot of Western audiences.
He escaped from the
Gulag, he had written
about the horrors of
the Soviet regime,
but when he came to
the United States
and was asked to give
a commencement address at
Harvard in 1978, he focused
most of his criticism,
most of his polemical
fire at the west.
And he felt that the, obviously
communism was a horror,
and he knew that,
and he denounced those as
much as anyone and helped open
the world's eyes to it.
But he also saw a kind of
diffused tyranny in the west,
but it wasn't any of
a central government,
but the tyranny
of private actors,
each just kind of pursuing
a base account of freedom.
- Which I think, if you
now move forward, you know,
roughly 40 years,
he was kinda right.
- Yeah.
I mean, especially, I mean,
I think big tech censorship
to me is that's just the,
a really good example of this.
There's this, in our
tradition, a wonderful right,
like journalism holds
power to account.
And now you have big
tech censoring, you know,
the newspaper I worked for,
New York Post, repeatedly last
year, for stories where we,
on both accounts
we've been vindicated,
Both the Wuhan lab-leak theory
and a Hunter Biden story,
and a certain kind of
libertarian autonomy
maximizing person
would say, well,
it's private actors doing it.
Who cares? Build
your own internet.
But a humane person
would say, look,
if these rights mean anything,
then it's possible for
a private actor as much
as the government
to violate them.
- Yeah.
I mean, the founders
could have never imagined
a powerful entity, so
much that it would dwarf
the entire government,
and here we are,
that's why I've moved on this,
I don't make the purely
libertarian argument any more.
- Michael Anton makes
his point beautifully
in the June issue
of "First Things"
that they just didn't
foresee this degree
of private power.
- They just couldn't have.
I mean, I don't
think there's any way
that they've could have
possibly imagined it.
Question 10.
I thought this was
interesting because now
everything's public all the
time, is sex a private matter?
- Yeah.
I mean, look,
I think we live in a
sexually schizophrenic age.
In the one hand, you know,
we're told to pursue whatever
we want sexually as long
as we seek our partner's
consent and protect
ourselves against disease.
And that's the kind of
sex is just private fun.
On the other hand,
we live in the age of Me
Too where it seems like
that sexual liberationism
in some cases has empowered
some truly horrible men.
And the focal point of the
chapter is someone who,
a lot of people
will be surprised,
isn't a book written
by a conservative,
but it's Andrea Dworkin,
who was a radical feminist,
really '70s, '80s, and '90s.
And she was a critic of
the sexual revolution.
I mean, she came
at it from the left
and as she just
saw that, you know,
sexual liberationism
had, in many ways,
led to especially
degradation for women.
And I argue that, in some
sense, she was a traditionalist,
even though she would
hate to be in this book.
If she was still alive,
she would not wanna
be in a book next
to Augustine and St. Thomas-
- Now she definitely sounds
like a traditionalist,
but then, not so much.
- No, no.
But I argue that, so look,
the traditionalism of the
'80s where it was like, oh,
all these feminists talking
about, well, you were
celebrating a sexual
ethic that was only
20 years old.
And it was boorish and horrible.
And there's nothing kind
of Christian about it.
And there's nothing,
it's only a relatively
recent vantage.
And so the problem with
Dworkin was that she accepted
this diagnosis of
what had gone wrong,
or she proposed this diagnosis
of what had gone wrong
with sexuality in the West,
and what was wrong
with sex liberationism.
But because she was
such a hard leftist,
she couldn't look at
the older tradition
of sexual restraint, because
that was just the right
and it was bad.
Yeah.
- I get this from a lot
of my liberal friends,
they get to the end of
the road and then the end
of the road goes, oh, you know,
some of the conservative
stuff was right.
And that's where they suddenly
get very quiet, you know?
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
They don't wanna make
that final, uh-oh,
maybe I really was wrong
about some bigger stuff.
- That was her precisely,
because, I mean,
all the chapters are
fairly uncritical
of the figure profile.
The Dworkin chapter,
I'm pretty critical
of her and where I'm critical
is that she didn't see
the shortcomings of her
own worldview, ultimately,
and stopped short of going
all the way to look, well,
maybe sexual
restraint was right.
- Do you sense, that
that, right there,
that inability to
get that last step,
that that's more of a
condition of a liberal mind,
something like that?
- Well, I mean, I wanna be fair.
I think it's a
shortcoming for all of us,
where your worldview takes you,
you may stop short
of going all the way
because it's uncomfortable.
- Yeah.
- It's worthwhile to
try to avoid that. Yeah.
- Exactly.
- Question 11. What
do you owe your body?
Which I thought was
really interesting,
because we talk a
lot about, you know,
your body your
choice, and now it's,
everybody's gotta get jabbed
and everybody's bodies,
everybody or we're gonna
kill grandma, et cetera.
- I mean, the chapter
is really a critique
of modern Gnosticism.
In the ancient world,
in 200, 300 years
after the advent
of Christianity a whole
bunch of religions popped up
that were unique in the
sense that they said
that human person
is not the bodily.
You are this kind of
immaterial spirit that happens
to be trapped in this
fleshly apparatus,
and you can do whatever
you want with it.
The body itself
doesn't have a norm.
What you should try to do
is to liberate this divine
spark that's trapped within you.
And that might sound
familiar to some moderns
because many modern movements
have the same tendency.
Transgenderism, which
we've already talked about,
is premised on the idea
that there's this dramatic
rupture between who we
feel we are interiorly
and the bodies that we receive
from nature which are sexed
and you're either
male or female.
Transhumanism is
another example of this.
There's movements
that think, look,
the human being
is just the mind.
And so if I can download
the mind into some kind
of software form and
untether what it means to be
human from this, again,
this body that's prone to
decrepitude and disease
and ultimately death,
then that's liberation.
But the problem with all
these kinds of movements
is that they're an invitation
to, not only unreality,
because our bodies
are just ultimately
a part of us, but also an
invitation to irresponsibility.
If I'm me, I'm not the person,
including this body,
then I don't have all
these inherited obligations
to family, to the people
who bore me and gave me
the shape of my body,
to my larger community,
because I'm the sort of
spirit creature and I can go,
I can use Bitcoin, I
can use virtual reality
and I don't need
physical contact,
I don't need to
shake anyone's hand.
And actually I think the
lockdowns kind of have
a Gnostic tendency, by the way.
You know, people would
just say, well, its just,
universities should just
be an online phenomenon.
We should always wear a
masks because, you know what,
we don't need to
see their faces.
And even if we've conquered,
COVID there are other,
there's the flu.
We could always
conquer the flu, too.
And that, I mean, all
these tendencies, I argue,
trace back to this ancient
heresy of Gnosticism.
- Yeah. Well, they're
deeply human needs.
A couple of times
during the lockdowns,
I've done meet and greets here
in LA, which, I don't, now,
I guess, there're
semi-legal, I'm not sure,
but when I've met people,
people literally crying
because they haven't seen
humans for that long.
They haven't seen someone
stand there and smile
and have a beer.
And it's like, that's
deep. We need that.
- That's so sad. But
we're human, yeah.
- But it's true.
- Yeah.
- The final question. This is
the final question, I suppose.
What's good about death?
- Look, I wrote that chapter
at the height of the pandemic,
and it's focused on
Seneca, the great Roman
stoic philosopher
statesman, who argued that
life becomes kind of
meaningless if you live forever.
And that it's not
that he was said to be
a foolhardy jackass and
like jump down 10 floors
and expect to live.
But to live in,
always in fear of death
prevents you from having
the right perspective
on your life.
You hoard your possessions,
you are fearful of
new experiences, you,
there's all sorts of things
that you do if you sort
of are just absolutely
fearful of death.
Whereas if you keep it in
a rational perspective,
and say, look, I'm gonna die.
It actually liberates
you to act, you know,
boldly in life and as
he did in his life.
But ultimately also that a
life in which you don't have
an end point is
kind of meandering.
It's like a novel that
doesn't have a beginning,
middle and an end.
And those kinds of novels
or movies are terrible.
All the things we
value in life, heroism,
sacrifice, true beauty.
They all find their meaning
in relation to an endpoint.
If you could live forever,
they're all kind of cheapened.
And, now, obviously a
Christian or a faithful
Jew or Muslim wouldn't
agree with him,
because he would say
there's an eternal life,
but they would agree with
him in so far as saying,
with Seneca, that is,
that this version of life,
of trying to bio-technologically
enhance life forever,
that's not eternal life, that's
a kind of fake substitute.
And I think that chapter
resonates with a lot
of people because of, frankly,
the COVID restrictions again.
- Yeah.
It must've been
fascinating just writing
that in the midst of COVID,
where it went from two
weeks to flatten the curve
to now we're locking down
for a year to then
rolling lockdowns.
And then suddenly it's like, oh,
we can't open up until there's
zero chance for anybody
to get it, which is actually
statistically impossible.
- And double masking
which is my least
favorite study. (laughs)
- And double masking
and everything else.
Let me ask you one other
thing that's not in this,
you did not pose the
question, but are you hopeful?
That seems to be coming up a
lot with a lot of my guests.
I'm trying to figure
out who's hopeful
for the future and why?
Are you hopeful that we
can turn this thing around?
Because a lot of the questions
that you pose here are
not things that we're grappling
with in a public sense
in any real way.
I mean, obviously,
certain people are,
the book's are doing well,
and we talk about these things
here, but at a public sense,
when you listen
to our politicians
and everything
else and just sort
of the trends of the world,
are you hopeful that
we can fix this?
- I'm theologically hopeful
in the sense that hope
is a theological virtue.
And I think God's in charge.
So in a very long term,
everything's gonna be okay.
In the short term...
No, I mean, the leadership
class in this country is such...
I mean, Biden has senility.
His senescence is so kind of
emblematic of this, but...
So no, I mean, in
the immediate sense,
but I do think the
depths that we're in,
and you have an audience
of people who you talk to,
I have an audience,
you sense that everyone thinks
there's something wrong.
Something's gone
wrong with the West,
and we can't quite put our
finger on it all the time.
I think that that yearning,
that sense of something's
gone wrong can be
the beginning of
a of an awakening
of a political
transformation of something.
So in the long-term
I do have some hope,
even more than hope, I have
optimism in the very longterm.
- We went from hope to
optimism. Pretty good.
The book is "The
Unbroken Thread."
The link is right down below.
Sohrab, I appreciate your time.
- Thank you, Dave.
This is great.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality instead
of nonstop yelling, check out
our spirituality playlist,
and if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, check out our
full episode playlist,
they're all right over
here, and to get notified
of all future videos, be
sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell.